help me understand because you know so
sometimes i get frustrated
from the outside looking in when i see
people who have real beef
with like real people who are from their
city like situations that you were just
talking about
but dan will beef with rappers that
aren't from their city and then that
equals [ __ ] and it's like almost like yo
like
rap beef is so it's turning into
something very serious obviously people
have lost their lives in some of these
beasts but yeah because this [ __ ] ain't
this [ __ ] ain't back then like how
you'll see
like
you'll see like field see like 50 50
or something ja rule or p diddy like
they'll be like
on the internet going back and forth
arguing like we're ready to real but
it's like you know never see nobody dead
behind it or you don't never see it like
go up for real for right so
[ __ ] on the outside from street
street standpoint like man i said fake
[ __ ] doing that that's a publicity
stunt or some [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
like like
us nowadays
like
it ain't no faking like we don't know
how to fake we too real for this [ __ ]
like we don't know how to fake like if
it's up it's up waiting for them
we ain't gonna do no [ __ ] i'm gonna stop
saying we me i ain't gonna do no [ __ ] to
hop on the internet and be like
i was up with him was cracking with him
and then we see each other we shake your
hands or we taking a picture or a photo
if i say it's up it's really that you
feel me but i got that side of me i come
to you and talk like a man and get
understanding you know what i'm saying
if it ain't no bloodshed behind or if it
ain't none serious
yeah i feel like the rap [ __ ] sometimes
like it turns it starts with something
like extremely weird and petty and then
sometimes it just gets serious quick
like it's like it goes from like some
weird internet [ __ ] someone's on
instagram live saying some passive
aggressive [ __ ] generating something
different yeah
the generation different uh temple's bad
[ __ ] just ready to go off the
bridge they didn't give them up yeah
yeah it's it's it's like it's
unfortunate too man because it's like
i just see this [ __ ] too much i'm like
you gotta be a [ __ ] like me you gotta
hide this head in this here yeah i got
two heads on myself what do you mean by
that what two heads on my shoulders yeah
this right here i can be this way right
here and i could be this way right here
because i've heard the music it feels
like you know you got you got some
pretty aggressive practice
yeah
um